Pollsters have been asking about impeaching
President Trump for some time.
In the latest Harvard/HarrisX poll, 42 percent
said that he should be impeached and removed from
office for his actions, while 41 percent said
no action should be taken.
There have been only a few ripples in this
trend since Harvard/Harris first asked the
question in June 2017.
Another question with a different emphasis
asked by Quinnipiac University since January
this year provides a different perspective.
In August 2018, 58 percent of registered voters
said that they would not like to see the Democratic
Party begin impeachment proceedings if the Democrats
regain control of the House of Representatives in November.
Thirty-six percent said that they should proceed.
A majority of voters in the June 2018 NBC News/Wall
Street Journal poll said that their vote in November
would not be a signal either way on impeachment.
Twenty-two percent said it would send a signal
to impeach Trump, while a similar 25 percent
said it would send a signal in opposition
to impeachment.
This is a sensitive issue with serious political ramifications. Let us know what you think,
let us know your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.